[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo tout de suite les
titres de ce vendredi 29 mars les
yvelines et les hauts-de-seine se
rapproche les deux départements
proposent une plateforme commune pour
l'emploi met en relation des
bénéficiaires du rsa avec les
entreprises qui recrutent
l'objectif favoriser l'insertion des
bénéficiaires du rsa souvent banalisé
ramener à de simples règles douloureuses
l'endométriose procure divers symptômes
reportage à suivre sur cette maladie
avec des témoignages de plusieurs femmes
atteint d'endométriose une maladie
encore méconnue et qui manque de prise
en charge
le professeur arnaud fauconnier
impliqués dans la recherche sur
l'endométriose sera notre invité nous
reviendrons également sur la visite du
préfet ou encore sur le lancement d'une
association de promotion de femmes dans
les yvelines comme chaque vendredi
coup d'oeil sur l'actualité de la
semaine le département des yvelines et
le département des hauts-de-seine ont
présenté hier une plateforme dédiée à
l'emploi en direction des bénéficiaires
du rsa objectif avec cette mutualisation
favoriser l'accès à l'emploi durable
augmenter le nombre d'offres et
faciliter le recrutement avec les
entreprises le reportage d'aurélie rose
et nicolas landry il suffit de quelques
clics pour créer son profil sur les
plateformes jobs 78 tout jobs 92 lancé
fin 2010 8 elles ont pour objectif de
favoriser l'accès à un emploi durable
des personnes bénéficiaires du rsa un
service désormais élargie aussi bien
pour les demandeurs que les recruteurs
chacun voit ce que les uns et les autres
blier soit en poste soit en offre est
donc peut rentrer en relation
directement on a une messagerie
sécurisée qui est intégrée dans l'outil
est donc dès que l'un ou l'autre voit
quelque chose un profil d'une offre qui
l'intéressent rentrer en relation
directement sans intermédiaire
cette plateforme est gratuite les
demandeurs d'emploi peuvent aujourd'hui
accéder à près de 1000 offres répartis
dans les yvelines et les hauts-de-seine
deux territoires complémentaires bassin
n'diaye bassin d'emploi du 92 et du 78
ça donne une puissance de feu
supplémentaires pour permettre le retour
à l'emploi des personnes en situation
d'insertion en matière de social en
matière d'emploi y a pas de frontières
encore une fois il faut savoir faire du
partenariat en septembre 2018 les
hauts-de-seine ont adhéré à xi vit-il
agence départementale d'insertion des
yvelines cette plate forme commune est
un nouveau symbole du rapprochement
durable voulue par les deux départements
ça avance bien j'ai bon espoir que la
fusion soit intégralement réalisée avant
la fin de l'année l ai fait la demande
et donc j'ai une réponse
si aucune date est encore clairement
avancé pour cette fusion d'autres
mutualisation de services devrait
intervenir dans les prochains mois
l'endométriose est une maladie
gynécologique qui touche une femme sur
dix avec moi en plateau le professeur
arnaud fauconnier bonjour bonjour vous
êtes impliqués dans la recherche sur
l'endométriose également chef de service
de gynécologie obstétrique au chu
poissy-saint-germain-en-laye vous est
également chercheur à l'université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
vous allez voir tout de suite le
témoignage de plusieurs femmes atteintes
d'endométriose mais avant professeur
arnaud fauconnier pouvez vous nous
expliquer ce qu'est la maladie bien
volontiers donc l'endométriose comme
vous l'avez vu sur le petit schéma c'est
une une maladie qui est causé par la
présence tout à fait anormal de
l'endomètre à c'est-à-dire la muqueuse
internat l'utérus endomètre qui va subir
les variations hormonales et la présence
de règle en fête et ses règles elles
vont avoir lieu en deux
or de la cavité utérine ils vont causer
des symptômes aient évolué et créer tous
tous ces troubles est ce que cette
souffrance dont les femmes se plaignent
dans les formes les plus graves de la
maladie
donc c'est une maladie non là dans la
cause n'est pas encore bien connus et
qui est assez fréquente
alors est-ce qu'on peut revenir un peu
sur les symptômes que ces femmes
ressentent alors dans les formes qui
sont symptomatiques parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de formes qui sont totalement
asymptomatiques les femmes ressentent
des douleurs qui s'apparentent à des
douleurs de règle puisque l'endométriose
la muqueuse endométriales est sensible
au cycle hormonal et donc va évoluer
enseignants et donc vous allez avoir
typiquement des douleurs de règles qui
sont très sévères et d'autres douleurs
au fil du temps qu'ils vont gagner
d'autres d'autres endroits
ce que j'ai appelé les douleurs de
localisation d'endométriose par exemple
les douleurs de rapports sexuels ou même
des douleurs intestinales des douleurs
pour aller à la selle ou des douleurs
pour uriner
il ya parfois aussi des symptômes
douloureux au niveau des côtes
parce que on a délocalisation de cette
maladie sous l'os dans les coupelles
diaphragmatique près du foie et c'est
très étrange mais ça donne ce type de
symptômes ce qui est caractéristique des
symptômes douloureux de l'endométriose
c'est très important c'est que ces deux
sont des symptômes qui sont extrêmement
invalidant qui sont sévères qui altèrent
profondément la qualité de vie des
femmes qui en sont atteintes c'est pour
ça que c'est très important de
distinguer les règles dans les douleurs
de règles banale qui sont liés parfois
une immaturité de la système génital des
jeunes filles des douleurs de
l'endométriose qui sont des douleurs de
règles extrêmement violente forte
invalidante
vous l'avez dit cette maladie procure
diverses souffrances vous allez
découvrir les témoignages de femmes
toute attente d'endométriose aux
parcours différents
immersion au coeur de leurs
consultations gynécologiques
c'est une maladie qui touche une femme
sur dix
je commençais à avoir vraiment des
douleurs comme si en fait on vous donne
des coups de poignard dans le dos le
ventre des médicaments ne fonctionnait
plus j'avais extrêmement mal et peur
aussi dorée avoir un prochain cycle on
va s'évanouir à des bouffées de chaleur
en zombies quoi oublier qu'ils souffrent
les douleurs dans la cuisse elle vit
terrée ap
cette maladie c'est l'endométriose elle
porte son du fait de la présence d'un
tissu à l'intérieur du ventre la plupart
du temps qui est tout à fait comparable
à l'endomètre qui le suc à l'internet
yahoo
d'où son nom d'endométriose il n'y a pas
une maladie mais autant de maladies
qu'il y a deux femmes avec des symptômes
très multiples pour la société
l'endométriose est perçue comme une
maladie psychosomatique
on me donnait du coup du mur fait non on
disait que c'était normal que voilà
c'était des règles on se dit tout le
temps que c'est normal d'avoir noué
pendant ces règles en fait pas comme ça
en tout cas
est-ce que vous avez déjà avec ses idées
reçues la prise en charge est plus
longue
charlotte a commencé à se plaindre de
douleurs importantes en novembre 2010
est elle se tourne vers plusieurs
spécialistes c'est un parcours du
combattant qui commence pour elle
à la suite d'un irm le diagnostic tombe
un an plus tard elle est atteinte
d'endométriose leterme fait un peu par
qui on connaît pas en fait moi on m'a
annoncé sa entre deux portes à la fin de
l'irm
à paris c'est un coup de massue après
c'est un soulagement aussi de savoir
qu'on n'était pas folle et que
et que voilà il ya une vraie maladie qui
explique tous les symptômes qu'on peut
avoir
je rentre dans les détails
est ce que c'est votre début du rapport
ou c continue au fond l'endométriose est
une maladie qui joue sur la vie intime
des patientes puisqu'elle ressentent des
douleurs pendant les rapports sexuels
j'ai commencé à ressentir d'extrême
douleur lors de mes rapports sexuels je
vais seigner énormément et je comprenais
pas trop ce qui m'arrivait il existe des
moyens pour soulager la douleur mais
aucun traitement spécifique n'existe
pour l'instant certaines patientes se
tourne alors vers la médecine douce
valérie barthélémy est spécialisé dans
la rééducation périnéale
depuis quatre ans on a avec nous un
matériel assez performant qui nous
permet par électrostimulation de pouvoir
soulager le patient directement en un
travail final et il ya aussi une grosse
part de discussion l'écoutent et la
parole sont primordiales pour ses
patientes atteintes d'endométriose qui
se sentent souvent seuls face à ce
manque de prise en charge cette gen
maladie qui est compliqué qui est dur
psychologiquement physiquement et on se
retrouve tout seul en face aux autres
souffrances pour ces femmes
l'endométriose est la première cause
d'infertilité non infectieuses en france
aujourd'hui
j'ai appris que j'avais un
vieillissement accéléré et que du coup
je vois congelés mais aux vues voilà
assez d'effectifs à prendre avec des
premières douleurs à 10 ans et demi mais
diagnostiqué à 19 ans audrey vient de
subir sa troisième opération
vous aviez une très belle renommée
trieuse là où il y avait de la teinte là
en tout cas visible on a tout enlevé ne
pas perdre espoir même lorsqu'on est
attendent d'endométriose à 28 ans audrey
a réussi à concevoir un bébé par
fécondation in vitro puis un deuxième
par voie naturelle deux enfants en et en
attendant de maîtrise
j'ai eu par miracle une petite lucie qui
s'est installé et on ou trois mois j'ai
appris que j'étais enfin une marche
mondiale est organisée par rando france
ce samedi le départ est fixé à 15 heures
sur le parvis de la mairie du 15e
arrondissement de paris avoir mal
pendant ces règles c'est normal vous
êtes une chochotte des phrases typiques
que les femmes atteintes d'endométriose
entendent souvent comment lutter contre
ces stéréotypes
je crois qu'il ya une information
d'abord du grand public et des femmes
elles mêmes à donner alors bien sûr le
c'est pas si simple en fait parce que
les douleurs de règles c'est un
phénomène qui est extrêmement normale et
banale chez une jeune fille puisque
quand on a nous fait des recherches en
population générale on arrive à 90 % de
femmes souffrant de douleurs de règle et
comme l'a dit une des personnes du
reportage ccc des douleurs de règles
endométriose et des douleurs de règles
sont particulièrement violentes et à
l'air tente donc je crois qu'il ya un
effort de pédagogie à faire c'est à dire
que dire à une femme que d'avoir des
raids des douleurs de règles c'est
normal ça veut rien dire il faut mesurer
ses douleurs de règle avec par exemple
une échelle de douleur il faut évaluer
la consommation d'antalgiques par
exemple si on prend comme l'a dit l'une
des personnes du reportage des dunes
européenne des antalgiques qui ne
fonctionne plus
c'est profondément anormal et de toute
façon qu'il y ait en dôme et rieuse ou
pas une prise en charge est nécessaire
avec un traitement spécifique ou non
mais je crois que c'est l'éducation elle
est aussi au niveau du public au niveau
de ce qu'on appelle les soins premier
c'est à dire que les gens qui les
médecins généralistes les sages femmes
ou le certains gynécologues de villes
doivent faire la prise en charge en
premier lieu de beaucoup de patientes
qui vont avoir des douleurs de règle que
je vais appeler bénigne et puis
sélectionner celles qui doivent avoir
des examens plus approfondis
alors justement pour ces femmes
atteintes d'endométriose il ya un manque
de formation du corps médical
écoutez ces témoignages d'abord aux
médecins généralistes soient mieux
formés pour reconnaître rapidement et
nous rediriger vers gynécologie le plus
rapidement possible parce que
effectivement on se dit tout le temps
que le c'est normal d'avoir mal pendant
ces règles mais en fait non pas comme ça
en tout cas à la famille est là bas on
vous dit il faut trouver un bon gynéco
sauf que un bon gynéco on sait pas trop
ce que c'est en principe chaque gynéco
et aptes à déceler normalement cette
maladie faim les maladies gynécologiques
l'endométriose a été découverte en 1860
et il ya toujours un manque de formation
des connaissances il ya un manque de
formation c'est un fait mais il faut pas
banaliser le fait que le diagnostic est
beaucoup plus difficile que pour un
fibrome par exemple quand vous avez un
fibrome ont fait une échographie on le
voit tout de suite ça saute aux yeux
vous faites l'endométriose c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué et les examens
radiologiques ne sont pas performants
parce que les symptômes sont les signes
radiologiques sont faibles et difficiles
à interpréter il sujet à variations d'un
radiologue à l'autre c'est la même chose
pour l'examen gynécologique
vous pourrez dire voir un gynécologue et
tout de suite on va voir que c'est une
endométriose mais moi dans ma pratique
je vois bien qu'il ya une errance
diagnostique avec même des gens qui ont
été vues par des
des très bons gynécologue je crois que
c'est il faut pas perdre de vue que le
diagnostic est difficile cette maladie
est très difficile à diagnostiquer avec
les moyens classiques c'est-à-dire
l'examen gynécologique et les examens
échographiques et irm qu'on voit souvent
fait alors justement pour soulager leur
douleur certaines femmes attendent
d'endométriose se tournent vers la
médecine plus douce
on l'a vu dans leur partage certaines se
tourner vers la chine et d'autres vers
les ostéopathes les naturopathes est ce
que ça peut soulager leurs maux
je pense que c'est très important de le
rappeler ces médecines dites qu'ils sont
complémentaires
elles ont un réel pouvoir pour aider
dans la prise en charge de la douleur et
du bien-être et donc il faut noter il
faut vraiment les recommandés mais je
crois qu'elle ne se place pas en
concurrence avec la prise en charge
on va appeler spécifique de la maladie
c'est à dire que quand on a une
endométriose diagnostic et une prise en
charge et qui est responsable de
symptômes importants
la prise en charge soit hormonal par les
thérapeutiques hormonales soit par la
chirurgie est recommandée il ya des
preuves scientifiques de l'efficacité de
ces traitements pour guérir les douleurs
c'est mais il est important
d'accompagner les gens aussi dans une
démarche de bien-être
l'acupuncture par exemple et efficace
avec avec des études qui le prouve la
nutrition il ya beaucoup de prise en
charge
l'ostéopathie et moi dans ma pratique je
recommande c'est en en adjuvant en
complément d'une prise en charge mais je
crois qu'il faut pas se détourner de la
médecine de la médecine
on va dire classique quand on a une
endométriose
importante parce que à ce moment là il
ya une perte de chance elle se tourne
également vers des psychologues car
elles se sentent seuls et parfois isolé
en manque de prise en charge pour
certaines
écoutez c'est compliqué financièrement
parce qu'il ya on passe en tas d'examens
au préalable avant qu'un diagnostic soit
posé c'est déjà une maladie qui est
compliqué qui est dur psychologiquement
physiquement et on se retrouve tout seul
en fait c'est compliqué à force de
rendez-vous de recherche d'examen ça
c'est compliqué de se soigner c'est un
choix après se soigner ou de logique
arnaud fauconnier une réaction mais moi
je suis tout à fait d'accord c'est une
maladie qui est une souffrance invisible
la maladie qui est effroyablement
difficile à gérer au quotidien de ces
femmes
je le sais nous le savons tous il y à
une prise en charge psychologique est
recommandée lorsqu'on a fait les
recommandations pour la pratique on a
recommandé cette prise en charge
psychologique
en parallèle d'une prise en charge
médicale
le problème effectivement qui est
souligné c'est l'absence de prise en
charge dans leurs remboursements donc on
espère que il y aura des discussions sur
avec les nouveaux modes de financement
qui sont proposés dans la prochaine loi
santé on pense qu'il pourra y avoir une
prise en charge plus globale un
financement plus global qui inclura
notamment des sessions avec avec des
psychologues
mais moi je pense que c'est fondamental
que les services de soins se dote de
psychologues et que ça fasse partie de
la prise en charge autre souffrance pour
ces femmes atteintes d'endométriose la
difficulté pour concevoir un enfant
l'endométriose est la première cause
d'infertilité non infectieuses en france
comment expliquer ce problème pour
concevoir un enfant
alors le l'infertilité lié à
l'endométriose est réelle puisque on l'a
dit dans le reportage c'est la première
cause non infectieuses de l'infertilité
féminine donc c'est totalement réel
comment l'expliquent pas très bien
justement il ya beaucoup de
probablement il ya beaucoup de causes de
l'infertilité par lord howe et rios par
exemple les adhérences le fait que les
troncs peuvent être touchées le fait que
les ovaires comme elle comme l'a dit
cette jeune femme qui à qui on disait
que ses ovaires vieillissent
prématurément
l'endométriose qui touche les ovaires va
détruire le tissu ovarien et rendre les
patientes avec une infertilité ovarienne
qui est difficile à traiter
donc il ya plusieurs mécanismes il faut
savoir quand même que quand une femme
est atteinte d'endométriose il n'est pas
du tout certain qu'elle soit infertiles
elle peut tout à fait concevoir sans
aucun problème avec une endométriose
même parfois c'est assez grave
donc c'est là toute la difficulté de
proposer une bonne prise en charge est
justement comment dépister
l'endométriose vous avez fait en soutien
avec endo france un auto questionnaire
destiné à faire son propre diagnostic
est ce que vous pouvez m'en dire un peu
plus alors je suis très content que vous
en parliez en fait ce questionnaire
c'est un an
c'est un projet donc aujourd'hui n'est
pas encore complètement validé mais
l'idée étant que on s'est rendu compte
que dans le délai très lo de diagnostic
des femmes atteintes d'endométriose qui
est de 7 ans en moyenne
quand on regarde acquis et du le délai
on dit bayal médecin qui a kiss et qui
n'a pas qui n'a pas tilté qui n'a pas
fait tilt mais dans la moitié du délai
est liée simplement une auto
banalisation des symptômes d'une femme
qui dit non c'est normal ma mère m'a dit
que c'était normal d'avoir de souffrir
pendant les règles de souffrir pendant
les rapports et donc et donc il ya on ne
parle pas des symptômes
donc l'idée c'est de dire avant d'aller
voir le médecin
on pourrait imaginer de cibler un
certain nombre de femmes qui ont
un nombre de symptômes douloureux et une
invalidité du fait des symptômes
suffisamment importante pour bénéficier
d'une prise en charge dite de diagnostic
précoce alors il y a eu cette affiche en
fait le questionnaire il est simplement
fait de questions autour des douleurs de
règles autour des douleurs de rapports
sexuels
autour de douleurs de digestif ou
d'autres douleur douleur pelvienne
mais quand on a fait la campagne
d'affichage avec les règles l'avait vu
sûrement les règles c'est pas normal
j'en parle à mon médecin etc
cette campagne d'affichage elle a
produit une prise de conscience mais
surtout elle a amené beaucoup de jeune
fille avoir des examens qui ne sont pas
utiles et qui montrent qu'ils peuvent
montrer des choses qui n'existent pas
imparable quand on fait une irm on sait
qu'il ya 20% d'image qui sont
interprétés comme de l'endométriose mais
qui sont pas de l'endométriose avec
derrière toute l'inquiétude que ça peut
générer
et puis toutes les gestes chirurgicaux
qui peuvent ou les gestes ou des
thérapeutiques hormonaux qui peuvent
être générées pour rien et donc
l'objectif de ce questionnaire qui est
en cours de test c'est de cibler une
population à risque et nécessitant une
prise en charge dans tous les cas d'une
symptomatologie douleur douloureuse et à
risque élevé d'endométriose dans lequel
les examens pour être être prescrits ce
samedi se déroulera la 6e édition de la
marche mondiale contre l'endométriose
organisée par rando france départ à 15h
sur le parvis de la mairie du 15e
arrondissement de paris
ça se passe samedi à 15 heures merci
arnaud fauconnier d'avoir été notre
invité je le rappelle vous êtes chef de
service de gynécologie obstétrique au
chu poissy poissy saint germain
vous êtes également chercheur à
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines
merci de votre invitation nous passons à
notre rubrique ça s'est passé comme
chaque vendredi et nous ouvrons nos
archives et nous revenons en décembre
2002 pour un bilan sur la progression du
vih
l'association sidaction aura à 25 ans le
week-end prochain
le message reste le même même si la
médecine
progress
[Musique]
ce dimanche 1er décembre avait lieu la
15e journée mondiale de lutte contre le
sida
quinze années de lutte contre le virus
de l'immunodéficience humaine qui tue
encore selon l'institut national de
veille sanitaire l'île de france est une
des régions française la plus touchée en
2001 2,3 cas était décelée pour 1000
habitants
je me rends compte que la maladie qu'on
croyait
envoi de
non pas de disparition bien entendu mais
des diminutions est en train de prendre
un nouvel essor sur les yvelines selon
li nvs entre le 1er avril 2001 et le 31
mars 2002 21 cas de sida ont été
notifiés ce qui porte à 1159 cas cumulés
depuis 1978
le centre de dépistage anonyme et
gratuit implantée à l'institut de
promotion de la santé à trappes depuis
janvier 2002 a déjà accueilli 460
personnes à la fin du mois d'octobre
si la population venant faire le test
est plutôt hétéroclite les médecins
observent une présence accrue des jeunes
les rapports entre eux sont extrêmement
fréquents lie à peu je dirais de gens
qui ont des relations suivies avec le
même quand même personne la jeunesse je
dirais
qui à 20 ans à l'heure actuelle c'est
essentiellement elle qui a oublié qu'il
fallait faire attention
le profil des populations contaminées
évoluent les personnes hétérosexuelles
sont aujourd'hui davantage touchés
d'autre part certaines communautés sont
particulièrement exposés un des
principal foyer d'infection aujourd'hui
c'est l'afrique subsaharienne
donc il y a une vraie réalité de
l'épidémie dans cette communauté l'a
donc ce que comme sous le disais tout à
l'heure c'était d'abord de changer
le déni dans cette communauté en fierté
de ce mobile à entièreté de ce mobile de
se mobiliser
l'association aide s'est installée ali
ps depuis le mois d'octobre dernier pour
se rapprocher des populations à risque
souvent en situation de précarité
si la baisse de vigilance est
aujourd'hui l'une des causes de la
progression de la maladie en france
l'accès généralisé aux traitements
thérapeutiques y participe largement la
quadrithérapie et la trithérapie on va
le dire dans ce sens là sont des
traitements qui ne soigne pas ne sont
pas curatif pour la maladie mais qui
essentiellement retarde l'apparition de
cette maladie
ces traitements des effets secondaires
lourds les gens n'ont pas forcément
conscience
il est donc important de rappeler que la
prévention est la meilleure des
solutions
[Musique]
le préfet des yvelines jean jacques brot
était ce jeudi 28 mars en déplacement au
centre d'élevage et d'éducation jacques
bougnol un lieu qui forme chaque année
plusieurs dizaines de chiens guides pour
aveugles et malvoyants avec l'aide des
dons du grand public
un reportage de michael et demi d'euros
les chiens guides d'aveuglés l'honneur
ce jeudi 28 mars le préfet des yvelines
est venu visiter pendant deux heures le
centre d'élevage et d'éducation jacques
bougnol installé depuis septembre 2015 à
buc
au programme découverte des boxes de
maternité pour les shows et
démonstrations avec les éducateurs
spécialisés
c'était important de montrer une
activité assez méconnu qui est essentiel
pour le bien-être d'un certain nombre de
malvoyants et aveugles et que qui a une
fonction sociale humaine extrêmement
intéressante positive
au total une quinzaine de chiens sont
formées en même temps sur ce site de
2000 m² sont pris en main par 18
éducateurs des trois mois et demi pour
les rendre opérationnelles après au
minimum 18 modes formation ce sont des
chiens qui vont avoir une relation
extraordinaire avec leurs maîtres en eux
en lui-même est ce qu'ils sont
extraordinaires
en tout cas ils font tout ce qu'il faut
pour pour assumer la leur mission mais
ça c'est notre responsabilité de choisir
des chiens particulièrement équilibré
est particulièrement réactif à ce qu'on
leur demande
coût total pour la formation d'un chien
près de 25000 euros pour les aider les
lieutenants de louveterie désigneront
remis un chèque de 500 euros lors de
cette journée
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo vous
pouvez retrouver notre sujet sur le
lancement de l'association elie élu
local yvelines en replay sur notre site
internet tv 78 points comme passer un
excellent week end
[Musique]
je